hope you guys are well insha allah
i'm going to pull fighting on the screen
no not yet
i'm going to pull them on the screen i
just need to
set up the discourse to just bear with
me for
one second guys
319 viewers on the stream bro
probably a delay don't worry
all right i'm going to meet you guys now
they could probably hear already through
the echo i need to grab headphones but
all right you guys are
officially alive islamic
how you guys doing
can you hear us
yes i can hear uh i'm sure the guys can
as well people watching at home
uh wait someone say something
salaam alaikum perfect all right
all right i see i see y'all in like
little pieces
oh my god
like the normal view like the full
screen view yeah
yeah i like y'all's you know close-up
face but
likes guys bear with us bear with us for
the streaming we're new to this you know
inshallah
we're trying to establish a routine
right now
we'll let you guys know it might be
tuesdays and fridays
at 12 p.m eastern standard time for live
but tomorrow we got a very special guest
tomorrow we got hoop finesse it's going
to be at 6 p.m
in the meantime
i say without further ado we just go
right into today's topic
rami do you want to pull up that picture
bro
that picture that iman
gadzi or gadgy has put up on his ig
story
yeah
let me pull that up let me pull that out
by the way on her bro we got 447 viewers
live
how many likes should there be
bro 447 there should be at least 2 000
likes come on guys what are you guys
doing smash that like button
all right
bro i cannot wait to get a pc
i love my mac but
all right here
here we go
there we go so this is a post from uh
man gutsy on
his instagram hold up what hold up you
gonna switch the videos or you can keep
it like that
what do you mean
like i still got to i got to i got you
real closed up
like both of y'all i'll take a
screenshot y'all can see exactly what
i'm saying yeah because i mean the
people at home what they're seeing on
the screen is people at home can see it
bro it's fine
that was not english bro what that was
not english nor do i comprehend that all
right
so am i gonna see what do you mean post
it on his instagram there's no way i die
anything except muslim my name literally
means faith slash belief in islamic
theology it's no coincidence i was named
that the amount of times my mom got hit
pushed down the stairs and bloodied by
my biological father who was an
alcoholic it's a miracle we're both
alive the strength to fight through all
of that
may allah bless them both
i mean then he says i'm not religious at
the moment but i've always believed and
prayed to god literally from the age of
three
it was the only time i felt safe soon
i'll devote my prayers with purpose
masha allah
masha'allah do you want to repeat the
first line that he wrote bro one more
time there's no way i die anything
except muslim
okay based on this bro i want to say two
things and i want to hear what you guys
have to say too number one may allah
subhanahu wata'ala guide brother iman
to islam and to have abundance in iman i
mean i mean that's number one bro i'm
sure you're all on the same page
but number two i want to touch on that
fact where he said there's no way
i die
except as a muslim so
rami
as much
as i want to have hope
and faith and
may allah guide him in time
what's what's this about i don't want to
die except as a muslim i do want to talk
about this a little bit brother iman if
you're watching this you know
do we decide when we die do we know when
we die is that something we can plan
rami
no there's no way and um there's two
kind of
versions of this we can't plan when we
die how we die and all that stuff it's
not just how we die or when we die in
terms of the method of our death in the
time of our death but also the state
that we're in when we die we can die in
the state of believing in allah the last
day you know being muslim dying the
state of islam like allah mentioned in
the quran
you know
i think it was one of the prophets that
said do not die except as muslims right
and that's the state that we're hoping
for and i believe that's the state that
iman uh was trying to allude to that he
doesn't want to die in any state except
the state of islam but
let's say that he planned on you know
taking islam seriously or not just him
but anyone plan on taking islam
seriously next week
what if they don't make it to next week
yeah yeah they cannot control the state
that they're going to die and that's
something that only allah knows so the
safest thing we can do is obviously
practice from this millisecond and
onward
hmm
i don't know what about you bro because
it seems to me when the message is clear
to you
we have all these internal dialogue
telling us to wait it's not ready i'm
not ready there's no perfect time yet
you know but the reality is nobody knows
when their time is done
that means you said it bro
did you go through something similar bro
as a as a reverb before you accepted
islam did you have that self-doubt or or
that internal conflict like i'm not
ready yet
of course but remember when
when i was telling you i want to tattoo
my entire body
i was like oh let me tattoo my entire
body first and then i'll become muslim
and then what did i say
so ladies and gentlemen welcome back you
don't know another
name
what have you done in the process and
you didn't become muslim in this process
like what are you gonna what are you
gonna tell what are you gonna tell the
creator
oh i was just trying to tap my entire
body which
you said is forbidden
so i was gonna do it before islam so
um
i remember bro this was about an hour
before
that
and bro truth nah nah this was this was
the night before
you sure
because i swear we had a call like an
hour before the shot of the two
well yeah i mean i kept bringing it up
for sure okay yeah but it's do you
regret it though no
i don't regret it yeah i don't regret it
do you say do you think a lot of the
people on the other side they're gonna
say oh it's fear-mongering you know it's
like saying you know you gotta take the
jump what do you say about that
it's not fear-mongering
when you
conceive for what it is like when you
finally understand like
damn like there's there's definitely
more to life
than what meets the eye you know all
these questions that we have there are
answers to these questions why do we
have these questions well we wouldn't
have had these questions if there
weren't answers to them
we were put on this earth and um our
creator is trying to tell us the answers
to these questions that we have
instilled inside of us
he's trying to show us what it is that
we're here for what that you know what
we got to do and all this stuff
like when you understand that and you
understand that
okay
everything's very temporary there's like
a impermanence everything
i mean why would you waste time
i agree bro i agree as a reaver bro as a
recent reaver too it's barely even been
two years
what word of advice do you want to leave
brother iman gazi or gagi with and
anyone else that's kind of like you know
what
i'm in the dhonia right now i'm trying
to make it to the top of the dunya
i might want to become muslim i
definitely do want to become muslim
eventually but
it's eventually what advice would you
have for them what do you mean top of
the dunya
like they wanna they wanna level up in
the dunya bro
i think iman
is already leveled up in the dunya bro
if you look at the things that he's done
bro man
he's already leveled up in the dunya
um
the only thing i would tell him and i'm
pretty sure he's already doing this
because he already said what he said
but it's it's a private
journey
and that it's not one that needs to be
publicized at least not until you're
ready to like tell people that you know
yeah muslim now like who knows man this
man might already be muslim this man
might already be muslim but there's many
people out there that are muslim and
they just don't say anything
um it's a shame it's a shame but it is
what it is so if if he's not muslim
already then i would just say like take
it take it very slowly take it at your
own pace and at your own time you know
in privacy
definitely definitely i agree bro and
for those of you that don't know who
iman is he's an entrepreneur self-made
multi-millionaire by the age of i
believe 20 or 21 very young you know now
he makes videos on youtube showing you
how to do the same
um gives you the the cold hard truth
about income and investments and all
that stuff so may allah guide him and uh
without further do it on me if there's
nothing else you want to add to that you
can play that clip bro
all right well i thought you were about
to end it i was like damn that was quick
bro
no way bro no way guys get the likes of
let's see how many likes we have
371 come on guys let's let's smash at
least through 500 likes on this stream
that's how you help uh the algorithm
insha allah
and
allah all right
so i have it on screen for the viewers
and it might be on screen for you guys
as well can you guys see it by the way
on discord yeah all right let me know
let me play
question i haven't seen you answer what
are your beliefs your view on religion
and your perspective on the spiritual
side of life if you have one now i'm a
very spiritual person um well i say very
spiritual but i've always my entire life
been very open to the spiritual side of
things you know i've read texts all the
way from the bible to the caballian um
you know study the taoist uh principles
and teachings and and study different
philosophies of life like suicide and
really i like to pull in all of that
stuff together now
am i religious per se not really you
know i have a bible
somewhere laying around here i have a
quran upstairs in my office and at the
moment i'm just reading a bunch of
different religious texts you know
religion is such a
triggering topic for so many people uh
and you know i don't really have any
dogma about it um i like to study all
the different religions and for right
now i haven't picked one definitely in
the future i will commit to religion
because i do
in the purest sense i am a fan of
religion and i think it gives people
guidance i think for a lot of people
unfortunately religion is this thing
where they're like
oh it's fine religion will just take
care of me i don't believe in that at
all in the same way when you just look
at all these spiritual woo people
they're like oh i'm just gonna manifest
it i'm like
no that's not really going to work but i
think especially for someone like me
who's very type a and who's very
a go-getter i think religion
at its core is is a chance for you to
tap into higher consciousness and you
know religious texts like the quran the
torah the the bible really what these
are are you know their their playbooks
for how to live life in accordance to
what's been brought down from god and
whether you consider that person or
literally just higher consciousness was
brought down through these different
prophets you know buddha muhammad jesus
christ all these different prophets and
for me all religions are real and all
these prophets were real people and all
of these texts are all real texts and i
mean in all of these texts itself it
says that there are multiple different
prophets so you know i think for most
people if you kind of know this stuff
you can agree that there is a god you
can agree that all these religions are
valid and all of these prophets existed
it's just which
prophet do you think took off that
higher level of consciousness and most
accurately portrayed that information
and put it down into these playbooks so
i think if you're religious or spiritual
at all you can acknowledge all of that
or you're on the atheist side and you
just think that this is all bs and
whatnot and i totally respect that as
well too you know honestly whatever you
believe but i just don't personally
prescribe to the fact that like we came
here
from this big bang that ever all this
stems from the big bang and that
everything that's around us and that the
symbiotic relationship between every
single living organism on earth
just like the perfect symbiosis between
it all um is just a byproduct of human
evolution like i don't know i just don't
really believe in it you know i just
don't really buy it i think we are here
for a reason and i think there is a
higher consciousness once again i don't
know
if like i don't know if i view god as
this this
single entity or whether it's just this
overarching higher level of
consciousness i don't know yet i'm still
very early into my days when it comes to
religious reading and texts
and i would politely ask you that in the
comments or like you know if you ever
respond to my dms or whatever sometimes
i post photos of like different
religious books or spiritual books on my
table on my coffee table or whatever um
you know just don't talk my ear off like
i think the most beautiful thing is when
i said someone can take the time to
really educate themselves and then see
what religion or what sort of a
philosophy of life that they prescribe
to and i think that should be someone's
personal private journey so that's kind
of my view on religion spirituality etc
etc i am not i wouldn't consider myself
per se religious at the moment i'm
studying all the different religions and
i think definitely there will be in the
next five years there will be one
specific religion that i tap into and i
commit to and i decide okay this is the
sort of way that i want to live my life
and yeah i want to live in my life in
accordance to these religious principles
so
hopefully that makes sense i wish
religion wasn't such a touchy subject
for so many people as i said i feel so
um if everyone understood that and once
again this is this excludes the people
who don't believe in religion or
atheists or whatever like i respect that
too but um
i think life would just be so much
easier if every religion or religious
person understood that all of the
religions are correct it's just which
one you decide is correct to you would
be so much easier if everyone realized
that all religions are true it's just
which religion do you prescribe to or
resonate with the most so
yeah ladies and gents that pretty much
wraps it up for today's q a i hope you
guys have enjoyed down below
all right
one thing i want to start off by saying
is
i think he's very alhamdulillah very
open-minded alabasam i think what he
said is is fair i think it's a little
too liberal but it's it's like the
normal liberal kind of view you know so
you can't really blame the guy
uh the whole like
every religion is true it just
it's like what's your truth kind of
thing it's the same kind of line of
thinking that the lg hgtv community uses
you mute it right now fired
i was going to say the the hd lg tvs
right the other ones yeah it's the same
line i think they use the whole just
your truth whatever is true to you is
correct and i mean yeah it's a nice
thought but it's that doesn't make sense
if if the trinity is true
and islam is true then the trinity is
also false it's a conscious it doesn't
make sense
but to put it in a nutshell so may allah
got him i think that he's definitely on
the right path because he's he's
open-minded he's looking into it and
some of what he said is in line with
islam like all gods and different
prophets and so on and so forth i think
he's just missing like anh always talks
about pieces there's peace here and a
piece there i think he's just missing a
bit of the the peace that will push him
towards islam but i think that's when
insha'allah muslims come in so you know
maybe not us but if he has a
conversation with some muslims and they
get to tell him about islam and what it
preaches and the fact that every
religion
has maybe some truth in it but they
can't all be the religion they can't all
be the truth that you should adhere to
and you should find basically what he
said which represents he says higher
consciousness well i'm just going to say
which represents the truth that god has
sent down the most the most accurately
and islam is the only one that does that
to this day so i think it's it'll be
good insha'allah
for us to invite iman onto the podcast
so we can discuss with him and if he
doesn't want to do it publicly we can
talk privately inshallah
what do you guys think
i think that
that's exactly it i think that he just
needs a little bit more time
so look into these things because it's
it's the pieces that you just said
he hasn't
he hasn't seen all the pieces yet right
maybe he's under this uh
this preconceived notion that okay
they're all the truth and it's just a
matter of which one is your truth which
one are you going to
um because back in the day
when i was in the whole spirituality and
all this stuff
and i was doing you know things that i
won't mention
uh a thing that kept coming up during
these trips was um just truth just truth
like you have to choose you have to
choose and i didn't understand then you
know until later on but it's like if he
if he just looks into it a little bit
more and when i say looks into it i'm
talking about all of the things he's
already looking into so i'm not telling
him to do anything crazy i'm trying to
do what he's already done
if he looks into this and he starts
seeing like okay um
this is this piece that says that piece
this is this piece he's never been get
to the point where it's like ah well
some of them have more pieces than the
other so this so-called truth that he's
saying like all of them
is uh the truth it's more so all of them
have pieces of the truth some of them
have more pieces of the truth which ones
have more pieces of the truth why do
they have more pieces of the truth and
then it just leads him down this pattern
until he gets to the point where he sees
the islam has all the pieces of the
truth
this is where we it'd be nice
for
if like you said if not us then
someone someone with muslim was able to
talk with him and have that conversation
that's the thing bro that was
beautifully said mashallah by the way
but you know the torah the injil we as
muslims it's explicitly mentioned in the
quran by allah that you know these were
sent by allah right so we can't deny it
but the modern day the old testament
that's not the torah bro the the modern
day new testament that's not the bible
bro you know that's not the real injeel
you know
and all of these religions you know they
have commonalities there's no way they
could all be by coincidence right it's
always been saying that we've sent
revelation we've sent messengers we've
sent prophets right there's a day of
judgment coming up there's all these
things coming up
there's angels you know there's books
there's one god that's the original true
uncorrupted unadulterated message and
that's all we're inviting all these
people including brother imam into the
idea that yes perhaps many of these
religions may have been sent by god may
they may be all valid initially but
saying that they're all valid today is
redundant because they can't be because
they're all contradicting in some way
form another
it kind of it's like saying you know all
these different things all these
different differing truths are all valid
they can't be there can't be two truths
i know this this might sound you know
harsh in today's liberal society but
that's the truth bro as rami always says
you know there can only be one truth
objectively speaking so if we know
understand if we now understand this we
understand that okay
we must find this truth we can
disqualify all the things that are wrong
or find a way to qualify one thing which
is right
we will definitely insha allah in the
next few days and weeks coming up
remaster some of our old og videos about
you know why i believe in god in the
first place why islam is the truth and
all that brother and humble
say something
yeah no i was gonna say when he was
talking about the whole privacy thing
like i i vibe with that because i said
it beforehand where it's like this is a
private
journey by yourself you know you you
come to a love by yourself you shouldn't
be like publicizing or trying to like
get the answers from other people
um though it's not a bad thing to get
answers from people who have the
knowledge and can lead you in the right
direction
but
he had gone on to say that it's
something about like
people not
being in your dms like just trying to
like say this isn't that about it and
it's like i get that but at the same
time like
think about this right you just found
something
that's blown your mind
it's changed your life entirely
like it's something that
it's
i don't i can't know what other way to
put it there is change your life it
changes life right
would you or would you not want to share
that with the people closest to you
that's all it is when people are like
saying these things and they're trying
to like
i i guess
for like a bit of word shove it down
your throat it's because they're so
passionate about it because they
to them it's very
it's something that's very strong that's
like affecting them very strongly
and at that point
you gotta ask yourself okay is it better
to keep it to myself or is it better to
actually speak out and say these things
because
if you know something
wouldn't you want to share that with the
people
that are closest to you wouldn't you
just want to share that with the world i
mean here i am on youtube making youtube
videos about my journey about some
random things that i'm realizing it's
like why why would i even do that why
would i make a video sharing this
experience about let's say me going
through nofap
why would i share this because it
changed my life it helped me i want to
share that because maybe
maybe it just might help someone else
so i hope you understand what i'm trying
to say there
lowrance
with that being said
any final points you want to touch on
yeah by the way guys everyone smash the
like button and send this video to
brother iman bro
at him on twitter with the link comment
on his instagram post dm him whatever
you can we need to make sure he sees
this and inshallah we can have a
conversation with him iman if you made
it this far bro for whatever reason we
invite you on or off camera again we're
not doing this for any ulterior motive
or anything you know wallahi you know
you have that
between
that we can do this off camera we can
talk to you privately can't even be an
audio call bro we don't even care about
that just we need to talk to you and we
you know we we agree with a lot of the
things you're saying but we do want to
correct some of the things and inshallah
shed some light on it
i'd just like to have some
conversation do you seem like a real
genuine dude yeah he does bro
yeah
yeah but um and this isn't just about
him you know obviously we're using him
as an example and uh asking him to come
out and talk to us insha'allah so we can
kind of tell him about islam you know
the religion that he wants to die in the
state of believing alhamdulillah
and inshallah grant us all that i mean
but it's not it's not just about him
right there's many many people i think
in his
in that kind of mindset out there you
know what i mean is it just me i mean i
i feel like this is the bulk of of
people
they're either maybe leading to a
religion they're not sure of but no one
very few people are actually committed
to a religion you know whether they're
muslim or christian or whatever a lot of
people
and they don't understand this and i'm
going to keep talking about it because
it's it's true and it's not talked about
and it's very important everyone's
living a secular liberal life this is
something that's taught to us
it's kind of like top and in the fine
print it's something that when you go to
school
this is presupposed you don't have a
class on liberalism in grade three but
everything that you're taught everything
that you believe inside outside of
school in the world
presupposes secular liberalism someone
said turn up your gain okay i hope that
helps inshallah
and let me do this as well
all right hopefully that's better so it
just presupposes secular liberalism
secularism meaning divide of church and
state
that religion is just something that you
can practice in your personal life but
it has no bearing on the legal
uh policies of the nation
and um liberalism meaning basically
maximize your pleasure especially
physical short-term physical pleasure
and try and minimize pain well that's
more utilitarianism but liberalism is
kind of just go for what makes you happy
or pleases you or whatever and most
people don't even really know what will
make them happy especially long-term so
everyone's in the state of like oh yeah
there's this religion that religion i'm
a muslim i'm a buddhist i'm a whatever
and they're not actually super
practicing they just kind of say that
maybe some claim to identity maybe they
you know agree with some of the beliefs
whatever it is
but they're all kind of
secular liberal if you think about at
the end of the day
how did you see that
yeah
yeah
before before we became muslim that's
kind of how i was
it was like i definitely like delved
into these things but
it wasn't like 100 practicing with any
of it yeah it's not saying that i was
ignorant it's just
i didn't want to practice yeah you know
i was like
two like one foot in one foot out
yeah and even when i would practice it's
not like
i don't know it wasn't like
it wasn't how it is now you know what
i'm saying like
before i even became muslim
i had the experience that like
basically just threw me into islam
it was
it like shuttled me into islam
everything else all these other stuff it
was almost like
i would dip my toe in
might feel like a little better
but it wasn't like there was always
something that like was stopping me from
fully fully immersing myself in it and
again it wasn't the ignorance yeah it
was something else
now what is the other thing i can't
really explain
yeah but then again there's a lot of
things that we can explain in this life
100 i think actually that ties into the
second liberalism thing as well because
if you think about it let's say
let's say you went to like new age
whatever because that's something that
already ties into what you believe
that's something that's inherently
liberal in and of itself and this i say
this about people like you know for
example andrew t i'm just using him as
an example who
they already have their beliefs men
should be like this life should be like
that and whatever whatever and then they
look at islam
and by the way not everything he says
about islam is true about like killing
infidels and women and that stuff but he
thinks it's true
so he says if there is a religion i'm
willing to bet on it would be islam
but not because the reasons that muslims
are muslim for the reason
that he already agrees
in his own mind with certain things in
the religion so he's still making
himself the measuring stick of truth
which is liberal in and of itself so
let's say someone
let's say someone were to practice islam
or a new age atheist or no or not
atheism like new age kind of
spiritualism or whatever it is
and they find a certain practice in it
that they don't want to do so their
liberal side says well i won't do it i
don't feel like it doesn't make me feel
good whatever i feel like it's a waste
of time they're just trying to make
themselves happy and pleasurable and
whatever based on what they think maybe
it won't make them happy they don't know
they don't care so when you have someone
who comes into islam they're going to
feel that way about prayer about salah
because their ideology this is so
important their ideology is liberal
their ideology is not islamic as soon as
like you now on hell as soon as your
ideology becomes islamic everything
changes and that's why
the ideology that the land and your
heart is based upon is the most
important thing because allah actually
gives an example
an analogy of and this to be fair this
isn't about belief in ideology this was
about praying in a certain masjid
because the kuffar they would build
mosques and try and get the prophet to
pray in it when they were once a place
for like idol worship and that stuff
and someone please correct me if i'm
wrong that's as far as i'm off the top
of my head
and allah he actually gives a kind of
analogy he says what is better
a place that was built for the sake of
allah
or and this is the opposite this is the
opposing or
a building that was made on the edge of
a crumbling cliff that fell off into
hellfire because the whole foundation
was so bad you tumbled into the hellfire
because of it
that's what allah is saying your
foundation is so bad in here or in here
or both
that you're basically tumbling yourself
into hellfire so if your belief in
ideology is like liberal secular let me
just make myself happy i'm my own god my
desires run me money runs me my love for
women runs me whatever
you know where you're gonna end up going
but if your ideology like alhamdulillah
allah make us from amongst those but you
know inshallah us now where we believe
islam ideologically theologically in our
hearts in our lives bro we'll pray
because we know we have to and it makes
us happy or being allah compare that to
someone who's like well i only want to
do what you know makes me happy well if
making allah happy doesn't make you
happy then you know what kind of life
you're going to end up living am i right
did you hear that
hear what
all right i mean yeah i think it was a
green shot
damn
where are you right now all right maybe
i should not stop
don't worry about that don't worry about
that let's not talk about that on camera
bro
like fire bro you've been awfully quiet
man
bro i'm gonna be awfully quiet until i
get that new audio interface bro
the audio is good now though
you gotta turn on your lightsaber like
me bro
bro i would it's actually not plugged in
right now but it does that like
shuttery thing
right it doesn't stay still like
we can wrap up today's when someone was
asking yesterday why rami has a glowing
plant
you want to address that bro that false
allegation yeah you know that um you
know that beach that has certain algae
that like glows
yeah i put it in my plant
oh is that why it's flickering too yeah
algae the algae is dying so
uh lg is dying here drop that smash that
like button guys for the algae plant in
the back that's glowing right now
subhanallah bioluminescence
um if you made it this far comment down
below hashtag
story that we did with brother dom that
we just dropped yesterdays on our
channel check that video out insha allah
and tomorrow wednesday
september i believe seventh it should be
we got who finesse at 6 p.m eastern
standard time live now pre-recorded so
inshallah we'll see you guys for that
inshallah
we ending it this soon man
damn that's tough how long did we even
last 40 minutes
it's not bad though yeah i mean we're
doing another one tomorrow so yeah we're
doing another one tomorrow guys stay
tuned to that 6 pm tomorrow with hoop
venus we're going to talk about his pro
basketball career we're going to talk
about marriage getting on dean all that
type of stuff guys stay tuned for that
exciting stuff
isn't it his brother that's doing the
professional basketball they both did it
for a while bro and his brother's still
doing it yeah mashallah
my bad guys i'm going to get better with
the super chats inshallah thank you for
everyone who donated
um i saw some regulars and also this
last one sammy he says
brothers keep up the good the great work
i love you guys for the sake of allah
your bro your brother from saudi arabia
and elevate you
for the fifties
brother sami for that super chat and
sister brought them up for the super
chat a little while ago don't think i
missed that now
live all right
and with that being said
assalamu alaikum foreign
foreign